PROFESSOR: So where are we?
Well it's the closing lecture.
When we first started gathering
in this room three
and a bit months ago, there was
a photo essay in the Yale
Daily News with snow
everywhere.
On January 13, when our second
meeting began, campus looked
like this, and this, and this,
and this, and this.
Whereas exactly three months
later, the Yale Daily News ran
a photo essay with this, and
this, and this, and this, and
this, and this.
It's spring.
And we're done.
What did we do?
Well we started with Plato's
Republic and we ended with
Plato's Republic.
The seasons changed.
We, in some ways, performed an
intricate reading of one of
the most foundational
works in the western
philosophical tradition.
So what I want to do in today's
lecture is to take you
through the course, using
four different paths.
The first thing I want to do is
to think through how it is
that the course goals
were realized.
The goals of helping you think
about how material that you
learned in a lecture in
Linsley-Chit might relate to
material that you learned to a
lecture in WLH and how that
might relate to thoughts that
you had in the library or
ideas that came up in the
context of conversations in
your dining hall.
The second path I want to take
through the course is to go
back to the syllabus's initial
description of the three main
course topics and to point out
to you the way in which your
understanding of those
topics have changed.
So we'll look at the question
of happiness and flourishing
as we encountered it in the
works of Plato, of Epictetus,
of Csikszentmihalyi.
We'll look at the question of
morality as we encountered it
in the works of Kant and Mill
and again in the context of
trolley cases.
And we'll think about the
questions of social legitimacy
and political structures, both
within the context of Rawls
and Nozick, Hobbes, and
in the context of
the Prisoner's Dilemma.
In the third part of the
lecture, I want to move to
three themes, which I see as
having unified of course.
Three central questions, each
of which provides us with a
way of tracing a path
through our reading.
The first, unsurprisingly,
is the theme of
the multi-part soul.
The second, the theme
of luck and control.
And the third, the question of
the relation between the
individual and society.
And I want to close the lecture
with, what for me are
the three central quotations
around which I see the course
as having been organized.
One from Epictetus, one from
Aristotle and one, which we
haven't discussed yet as a
group, from the closing pages
of Plato's Republic.
So let's start out by
remembering what it said on
the syllabus that the goals
of the course were.
The syllabus told us that the
course had three goals, the
first of which was to "introduce
you to a number of
traditional philosophical
discussions that address
profound questions about the
human condition and to help
you think about ways in which
the methodology of philosophy
provides insight regarding
them." And in the course of so
doing, we encountered work by
Plato, by Aristotle, by
Epictetus, by Hobbes, by Kant,
by Mill, by Judy Thomson, John
Rawls and Robert Nozick.
And what I tried to provide
you with, in each of these
cases, were the tools to make
these texts your own for the
rest of your life.
Some of your exercises involved
learning how to use
the front material or the
indices or the critical
material that is attached
to the texts.
So in the case of Plato's
Republic and Aristotle's
Nicomachean Ethics we used
highly annotated editions of a
kind that let you make your way
into an ancient text that
might be otherwise
unapproachable.
In some of the cases the
problem was having the
terminology necessary to make
sense of technical words that
the author was using.
And there we learned to make
use of the Blackburn
Dictionary of Philosophy and
other resources as a way of
orienting yourself in texts
that seemed technical.
Sometimes the language of
the text got in the way.
So for many of you reading the
Hobbes in the original 16th
century English made it harder
to understand what the
concepts were.
And there we learned the
possibility of making use of
modernizations of texts as ways
of understanding them.
And throughout, with the reading
guides, the reading
questions, the lectures and the
discussions, the goal was
to provide you with the tools
so that for the rest of your
life when you look on your shelf
and you see your copy of
Plato's Republic you can
open it up and learn
from it on your own.
The second goal of the course
was to "introduce you to
related discussions of these
topics from the perspective of
other academic disciplines,
particularly contemporary
cognitive science and
psychology, and to help you
think about the ways in which
the methodologies of those
disciplines provide insights
regarding these fundamental
questions." So we started our
discussion of The Ring of
Gyges by looking at empirical
work by Daniel Batson inspired
by Plato's challenge as
posed by Glaucon.
When we looked at Plato and
Aristotle and Epictetus on
flourishing, we did so in light
Jon Haidt's Happiness
Hypothesis, which brought to
bear on these historical
questions study after study
from the contemporary
psychological tradition.
When we thought about how the
notion of parts of the soul is
manifest in our contemporary
idiom, we made use of the work
of Daniel Kahneman and Amos
Tversky, the heuristics and
biases tradition, as a way of
trying to use our vernacular
to think about insights that
have been part of every wisdom
tradition since human
civilization began.
When we thought about what Plato
meant by the harmonious
soul and what Aristotle meant by
the cultivation of habit to
allow virtue to become easy, we
thought about it in light
of Csikszentmihalyi's notion
of flow and considered the
ways in which that notion
might, in a contemporary
idiom, give voice to the
concerns that we saw in these
earlier authors.
When we thought about what the
costs of a disordered soul
might be, we read Jonathan
Shay's extraordinary work,
Achilles in Vietnam.
And we thought about the ways in
which the war experience as
described in Homer's Illiad
and the war experience as
described by returning veterans
give voice to a
common human experience in the
face of the loss of a certain
sort of structure.
When we thought about the ways
in which social activities of
those around us --
the inevitable human tendency
conform to the demands of
authority --
when we thought about those
questions and how they might
affect people we did
so in light of the
work of Stanley Milgram.
When we thought about how it
is that we might go about
cultivating virtue in ourselves
we considered what
implications that might
have for parenting.
When we thought about the
question of how it is that we
should explain our responses
to trolley cases, we
considered the question
of whether the neural
underpinnings with respect to
activations in particular part
of the brain might be doing some
of the explanatory work
to answer the questions with
which we were concerned.
When we thought about how it is
that we might make sense of
questions in political
philosophy and the legitimacy
of the social contract, we
helped ourselves to game
theory's notion of the
Prisoners' Dilemma and to the
idea of the Problem
of the Commons.
When we considered the ways in
which social structures affect
us, we looked at the question of
social norms and we thought
about the ways in which, though
we had cut a fairly
wide path through one
intellectual tradition, that
there was a world full of other
intellectual traditions
which we had barely touched.
In all of these cases the
goal, as with the
philosophical texts, was to
give you the tools and
resources to make use of this
sort of literature on your own
in the future.
You performed a directed
exercise where you were given
a core text and asked to find
articles that cited it and
articles that it cited.
You were asked to take a
particular article from an
empirical psychological journal
and to figure out what
question it was asking, what
alternatives it was
considering, what the logic of
the argument was, what the
methods were that were being
used, what the results were
and what the implications
were.
And then you were asked to
come up with your own
experimental design, having
thought through, in the case
of someone else's study, what
a study might look like.
The goal of this was not only
to introduce you to a broad
swath of psychological
literature, but also to let
you know that this too is
a body of intellectual
resources, which is at
your disposal for the
rest of your life.
The third goal of the course was
to help you to think about
your own education in a
synthetic way by "encouraging
you to be sensitive to how
insights from one academic or
other contexts might be echoed
or illuminated by insights
from another." This course is
a case study, a model, an
exemplar, for how it's possible
to look at a problem
from multiple perspectives.
And your final exercise, which
asks you to think about, for a
question that concerns you, how
you might bring multiple
perspectives to bear on it, is
an attempt to get you to
think, for the rest of your time
at Yale and the rest of
your time on this planet,
in a synthetic way.
To think about the range of
courses and choices that are
available to you as being
interrelated in exploring the
fundamental question that
defined human experience.
So that's path one through
the course.
Three goals.
Three skills.
Path number two looked
at three fundamental,
substantive, questions.
The question of what can be
said, at least in the context
of the Western tradition and
perhaps beyond, about the
conditions under which authentic
happiness and true
flourishing are possible.
The second was the question of
what sorts of demands morality
makes on us.
And the third was the question
of political legitimacy and
social structures and the ways
that those affect us.
So if you look back at your
syllabus you will see that the
set of questions which we aim
to explore there are the set
of questions which we
actually explored.
In the context of happiness
and flourishing, we ask
ourselves how we might think
about Plato's suggestion that
the human soul has various parts
in light of contemporary
work in psychology.
And we explored, not only
Plato's idea that we are
composed of a reasonable part,
a spirited, and an appetitive
part, but looked also at
numerous manifestations of
what's now known as the dual
processing tradition.
And we'll talk more about that
when we talk about the
organizing themes.
We asked ourselves how Plato's
and Aristotle's discussion of
the importance of friendship
and human attachment are
echoed in recent discussions
of human happiness and
flourishing.
And sadly because of the weather
that lecture was
somewhat abbreviated.
I promise next year when I do
the class to do it in more
detail and you're all invited
back, if you're on
campus, to hear that.
We asked ourselves how the
basic ideas of the stoic
philosopher Epictetus are
reflected in modern
therapeutic practices.
And we recognized that the
central insights he has --
of recognizing what is and isn't
in your control and of
realizing that one can set ones
desires in such a way
that the world feels
more cooperative --
lies at the center of modern
therapeutic practice.
And we read in this context the
amazingly moving words of
Admiral Stockdale describing the
ways in which the words of
Epictetus enabled him to survive
and even flourish the
degrading conditions
of a prisoner
of war camp in Vietnam.
We asked ourselves how
Aristotle's discussion of
weakness of the will-- what
he calls akrasia--
connects with current
discussions of procrastination
and how to avoid it.
And we presented ourselves with
various resources for
structuring our external and
internal environment in such a
way that our reflective
commitments could be what
guided our practice, rather
than our untrained habits.
And we asked ourselves how
Aristotle's reflections about
the role of habit in cultivating
virtue are
reflected in 20th
century and 21st
century parenting manuals.
All of those were questions
that we considered in the
context of happiness
and flourishing.
All of those were words on
a syllabus page, whose
significance to you three months
ago was, I hope, less
than it is now.
All of these are questions worth
asking yourself for the
rest of your life.
In the context of our discussion
of morality, we
asked ourselves what are
the basic tenets of the
fundamental moral theories,
which compose the Western
tradition: Aristotelian virtue
ethics, Kantian deontology and
Millian consequentialism.
We set aside, for the purposes
of this course, a fourth very
important strand that grounds
morality in religion.
But we have, as a result of
having thought through the
questions, what assumptions do
these theories make about
human nature and about the role
of morality, the tools to
think about even moral theories
that we didn't consider.
We looked for differences in the
moral theories, the ways
in which they emphasize
consequence or actor or character.
We looked at similarities among
the moral theories, the
ways in which they stressed the
importance of overcoming a
certain kind of first-person
exceptionalism.
We looked at the ways in which
these moral theories deal with
the gap between intention
and outcome.
And we looked at the ways in
which these moral theories do
and don't provide different
answers to particular
normative questions.
We went on to ask ourselves,
in the context of our
discussion of morality, how
recent experimental work on
moral intuition, particularly
discussions of the Trolley
Problem but also discussions of
related cases, relates to
traditional philosophical
discussions of morality.
And how this work connects
with contemporary work in
neuroscience and related work
in cognitive and social
psychology.
And through the discovery that
it was extraordinarily
difficult to come up with
systematic explanations for
why it is that our intuitions
were pulling us one way in one
case and another way in other
cases, we came to realize how
challenging it is to come up
with a systematic theory and
thereby gained further insight
on our original question about
the structure and complexity
of the human soul.
And we thought about, in the
context of our discussion of
morality, the relation between
moral responsibility and luck.
Recognizing, perhaps in the most
profound way, that some
things are up to us and
some things are not.
And that the relation between
good intentions and good
outcomes, bad intentions and bad
outcomes, are not as tight
as we might wish
they would be.
And we asked ourselves, finally
in this context, when
punishment might be justified
and what moral political and
psychological role it plays as
a way of thinking about the
counterpart of the
moral question.
And we learned thereby that one
of the ways of thinking
about how things should go when
they go right is to think
about how things should
go when they go wrong.
And thereby we gained another
tool for thinking about a set
of fundamental questions.
Like the questions about
happiness and flourishing,
these are questions to ask for
the rest of your life.
In the third part of the course
we asked a question
about the role of social
structures in allowing human
flourishing and moral
behavior.
And we actually previewed this
part of the course back in the
beginning section.
We asked ourselves what the
experience of Greek soldiers
in the Trojan War and the
experience of American
soldiers in the Vietnam War
tells us about the role of
social order, themis, in
allowing human beings to
function effectively.
And we, through that and through
the discussion of
Stanley Milgram's work, got our
first hint of the ways in
which much of what we are and
much of how we act is
determined, not merely by things
inside ourselves but
also by the communal structures
with which we are
surrounded.
And that makes all the more
pressing, the set of questions
that we asked in the final
unit of the course.
Inspired by Plato's opening
analogy, that to understand
the structure of the human soul
we must understand the
structure of society.
And to understand the structure
of society we must
understand the structure
of the human soul.
And we asked ourselves how it
is that the fact that we are
simultaneously desirous of
possessing objects that others
possess and desirous of being
able to be in a position of
security with respect to that
to which we have become
attached, we discovered that
there was a mathematical
representation, game theory's
notion of the Prisoner's
Dilemma, that could illuminate
Plato's discussion in the
opening pages of book two of
the Republic and Hobbes's
discussion in chapter thirteen
of Leviathan of the ways in
which social structures come
into being legitimately.
We then went on to ask
ourselves, looking at two
central texts in the 20th
century Western political
philosophical tradition, how
the work of John Rawls and
Robert Nozick bring out the
importance of what, in many
cases, seem to be two competing
considerations.
Considerations of equality, on
the one hand in the work of
Rawls, and of liberty on the
other, in the work of Nozick,
in structuring a just and
legitimate society.
And we asked ourselves how work
in social psychology and
behavioral economics might shed
additional light on these
fundamental questions.
And we asked ourselves finally,
in our discussion of
norms and basic social
structures and censorship,
what the proper role for
non-rational means of
persuasion, including mass
cultural influences such as
cinema, television and music,
is in a democratic society.
And we noticed, in an uncanny
way, that Dan Quayle's remarks
about Murphy Brown and the
Madden video games' views
about displaying concussions in
online gaming were echoing
almost verbatim the words of
Plato from book ten of the
Republic when he discussed
poetry and censorship.
So that's our second path
through the course.
The three fundamental themes
that we identified, the
sub-questions that we asked with
respect to each of them,
and the encouragement to all
of you to keep asking
yourselves those questions.
Path number three: three
organizing themes.
And I will, because I don't want
them to go to waste twice
during this section, ask you to
use for the very last time
in this course, your clickers.
So if you'll take them out for a
slide about four slides from
now and then a couple of
slides after that.
You will recall that we began
our discussion of parts of the
soul with Plato's famous
story of Leontius.
He writes in the Republic of
"Leontious, the son of
Aglaion, who was going up from
the Piraeus along the outside
of the north wall of the city
when he saw some corpses lying
at the executioner's feet.
He had an appetite to look at
them but at the same time was
disgusted and turned away.
For a time," writes Plato, "he
struggled with himself and
covered his face.
But finally, overpowered by
appetite he pushed his eyes
wide open and rushed towards the
corpses saying, look for
yourselves you evil wretches.
Take your fill of the
beautiful sight."
Tempted by corpses, perhaps
we are not.
Tempted by contemporary analogs
thereof, perhaps we are.
And we introduced ourselves, as
a tool for thinking about
this, to George Ainsle's idea
of hyperbolic discounting,
whereby a smaller, sooner
reward, one that from a
distance doesn't seem as
valuable as our ultimate
reward, comes as the result of
the way in which we relate to
value over time to seem more
valuable to us at a moment of
decision making.
So even if your goal is to spend
the weekend preparing
for exams, and even if now,
from the perspective of
Thursday, the larger, later
reward looms greater in your
mind, there is--
let me remind you-- the risk
that as you move closer the
curves will cross and you will
find yourself consuming the
smaller, sooner reward and
losing the larger, later one.
We talked about this in the
context of this class, where
more than 50% of you committed
to turning off the Internet,
either completely or restricting
your Internet
usage in some way in the
context of class.
And I asked you on January 25,
back when the snow still
covered the ground, how
successful you had been.
And at that time, of those of
you who had committed yourself
to some sort of restriction,
56% of you had strayed not
even an itty bitty bit.
25% had strayed just
once or twice.
8% said, well a few times
but I'm trying.
And 11% of you had fallen
off the wagon.
So the first clicker question,
I'll ask only for those of you
who made some sort of commitment
to yourself, is how
did it work out?
If you had the Internet pledge,
did you stray, one,
not even once; two, a few times
but not very often;
three, pretty regularly but not
all the time; or four, if
for example you're closing
Facebook now and looking for
your clicker, you might
want to push yep.
So let's see in the next 10
seconds how our numbers came
out in comparison to where
we were at the
beginning of the semester.
So of those of you who took the
Internet pledge, 30% of
you kept it tightly.
From all 30% of you, the
rest of us want advice.
Why did it work?
What did you do?
What enabled you to carry
through with your commitments?
Another third of you strayed a
few times but not very often.
But nearly 50% of you, despite
having resolved to do
something, were unable to
carry through on your
commitments.
One of the goals of this course
is to remind you that
both in the Ancient tradition
and in the modern dual
processing tradition, there are
theoretical frameworks for
understanding why it is that
we often find ourselves not
carrying through on what we were
committing to and how it
is that we might structure
our experience and our
surroundings in such a way
that that becomes easier.
So that's one of the ways in
which we thought about the
question of the soul having
parts in this course.
We also thought about the
question of the soul having
parts in this course as a rather
profound challenge to
methodology in any discipline.
We observed, in the context of
the heuristics and biases
tradition, that there are cases
where we are faced with
choices where we know what the
right choice is and we are
pulled one way by one
sort of instinct and
another way by another.
So for example, in what are
called frequency/probability
cases, where, for instance, your
goal is to choose from
the box where you have the
greatest likelihood of drawing
a red ball.
And one of the boxes has one red
ball and nine white ones--
a 10% chance--
whereas the other box has 8 red
balls and 92 white ones--
an 8% chance.
We know that there is a
tendency, when under cognitive
load or when exhausted, to be
pulled towards frequency--
the presence of eight red
balls over here--
as opposed to probability--
the 10% case over here.
But we also know that when we're
pulled towards frequency
rather than probability
in that case,
we're making a mistake.
In other of the cases that we
considered, it's not so easy
to know which answer
is the one that we
reflectively endorse.
We were presented twice in the
course with Kahneman and
Tversky's famous disease
problem.
A terrible disease has struck
600 people in your town,
you're the mayor and two courses
of treatment are
available: plan A and plan B.
It turns out that the plans
are identical.
But plan A is described as a
plan where 200 people of the
600 will live.
Whereas plan B, in the second
case is described as one where
400 of the 600 people
will die.
And so too with the
probabilistic
determinations of them.
But here are the data that
you as a class provided.
Those of you who faced the
green description of the
choice between A and B were
2/3 of the time preferring
plan A. Those of you who faced
the blue description of the
choice between plan A and plan
B, the one that phrased it in
terms of 400 deaths rather than
200 lives saved, showed
exactly an inverse proportion
of responses.
But in contrast to the
frequency/probability case
it's not clear what the right
way to frame a question of
decision-making under certainty
versus uncertainty is.
Should we think about
how many will live?
how many will die?
Which framing is the right
one isn't so obvious.
And this problem persisted as we
over and over again, in the
context of our trolley
discussions, found ourselves
giving different sorts of
responses to cases that were
theoretically challenging
to distinguish.
So only 15% of you thought it
was prohibited to turn the
trolley in the case
of the bystander.
Whereas 78% of you thought it
was prohibited to have the
trolley hit the fat man in that
version of the scenario.
We faced it again in the context
of our ducking and
shielding cases.
Almost all of you thought it
was fine, if a bear was
approaching you, to move out
of the way even if the
inevitable consequence was
that the bear harmed the
person behind you.
But almost none of you thought
it was acceptable, if a bear
is running towards you, to take
the person from behind
you and put them in front
of you as a shield.
Does that difference track
something real?
Or are those just the different
responses that the
different parts of
the soul gives?
Again and again we confronted
this when we thought about
ways in which we should use
not reason, but habit as a
method for regulating
behavior.
When we thought about flow as
a state of the harmonious
soul, where the parts of the
soul that can be pulling us in
different directions might
come together.
In the context of the role in
justification of punishment,
where we asked ourselves whether
there is any rational
justification for retribution,
or whether that only concerns
something which, on reflection,
we don't endorse.
We asked ourselves about the
relation among parts of the
soul in the context of our
discussions last week of the
influences of fiction, of norms,
and other forms of
non-rational persuasion
in shaping our lives.
And we asked ourselves about it
tacitly every single day of
this course when we thought
about the difficulty, or
perhaps impossibility given our
complexity, of reconciling
our intuitive and reflective
responses and reaching what
Rawls calls reflective
equilibrium.
That it is difficult to bring
principles and practice
together, that it is difficult
to bring systematic
understanding to particular
cases, does not mean that it
is not worth trying.
But that we discover ourselves
repeatedly frustrated by it
may in itself bring
philosophical lessons.
That's theme of the course
one: parts of the soul.
Theme of the course two: luck,
control and circumstances.
We presented ourselves as a
paradigm case to hold on to
with the contrast between
two kinds of characters.
On the one hand, Lucky Alert
and Lucky Cell Phone.
One, a person who did nothing
wrong drove home
and harmed no one.
The second, a person who perhaps
did something risky,
drove home and harmed no one.
And we contrasted those cases
with their unlucky
counterparts, who on their way
home, following exactly the
same course ended up, though
no efforts of their own,
harming a child.
And when I surveyed you about
this in March, almost all of
you thought that lucky alert
had done nothing morally
problematic.
97% of you answered that he did
not do something morally
blameworthy.
In the case of Unlucky Alert,
even though he brought about a
harm, still 81% of you were
willing to grant him full
moral exculpation.
But--
and I'm going to retest you
on this in a moment--
when I asked you on March 3
whether Lucky Cell Phone,
somebody who did a slightly
risky thing with no harmful
consequences had done something
morally culpable,
78% of you said that he did.
An answer roughly, though not
as extremely, in line with
your answer to the question
about whether Unlucky Cell
Phone did something morally
culpable, which 92% of you
answered yes to.
So I'm curious, because these
results perplexed me so,
whether another six weeks of
thinking about moral luck has
changed your views.
So question, our old friend
Unlucky Alert--
the one talking on his cell
phone who drives home and
harms no one--
Unlucky Alert you, who take
risks in your life every day,
risks which could cause
consequences that if they
occurred, you might regret
that you hadn't taken
precaution.
In so doing, oh holders of
clickers, do you do something
morally blameworthy?
And let's see how these
numbers come out.
So in contrast to your previous
assessment, where in
the case of Unlucky Alert,
81% of you thought he did
something morally blameworthy,
now only 36% of you do.
Why?
I don't know.
But it's worth thinking about
why that happened.
Let's contrast this with the
case of Lucky Cell Phone.
Sorry, I just asked you the
question about Lucky Alert and
put up the question and
articulated the question of
Lucky Cell Phone.
My data are distorted and
I'm going to have
to skip this question.
So I ask you to ask yourselves
at home what you think about
these cases.
But because I misphrased things
I need to go on to the
next point.
Although those are some
nice numbers.
What question they're in answer
to will remain a topic
for future research.
There has been--
I have only six minutes
remaining so I
want to talk quickly--
a fundamental and recurring
puzzle that we
faced in this class.
Determining what is and isn't
in our control regarding our
attribution of praise
and blame in cases
of unintended outcome.
Resolving the role all what is
and isn't in our control in
our own internal reactions
to events.
In our recognition of the degree
to which we're shaped
by our societal circumstances,
as explored by Aristotle and
Doris and Shay and Milgram and
the WEIRD studies and Sunstein
and Plato and exploring the ways
in which this should be
normatively factored in, both
politically and morally.
That's theme number two.
Theme number three: individual
and society.
Sometimes things which are OK to
do if you are the only one
doing them become problematic
if many others are.
There's no problem polluting
if most of the environment
remains clean.
There's a major problem
polluting if the result is no
air for anyone.
There's no disruption of
patterning if one of us
chooses to give money to
somebody whose work we admire.
But, as Nozick points out,
there is a disruption of
patterning if many of us
have the same response.
The costs of those kinds of
patterns may be minimal in
certain contexts, but in
others the fact that
differences arise between us
may cause a loss of our
fundamental democratic
institution.
So in the context of our
discussion of the relation
between individual and society,
we were taught, both
in the context of the moral
philosophy section and in the
context of the political
philosophy section, that if we
want to make real our
commitments to living as
members of a community, we need
to have a vivid way of
representing before ourselves
that we are
only one among many.
And we have two beautiful
articulations of that.
One in Kant's formulation of
the categorical imperative,
that my own desires may serve as
the basis for willed action
only if I can at the same time
coherently will that others in
similar circumstances would
act in the way that I am
choosing to act.
And in Rawls's articulation of
the veil of ignorance as a way
of thinking about what
justice demands.
What's beautiful about these
articulations is that they are
an attempt to bring a
consideration that reason had
brought us to into a formulation
that we can make
use of intuitively.
Their attempts to give us
vivid ways of remaining
committed to what all of you,
or almost all of you in this
class, suggested you
are committed to.
Which is in education, in
housing, in healthcare, and in
the distribution of resources,
to a somewhat more egalitarian
distribution of goods than might
arise if we didn't think
about our experience from the
perspective of the community
as a whole.
And I'll skip-- though put up
on the Internet for you--
three slides from a recent
study showing that your
responses in these cases
were not exceptional.
Let me close by pointing you to
three quotations, which for
me epitomized the course.
The first is the quote from
Epictetus that tells us when
we are about to encounter an
experience that we worry we
might find distasteful that we
need to think about what it
would be like and to prepare
ourselves for it.
What upsets people, says
Epictetus, are not things but
are judgments about them.
The second is the quote from
Aristotle, which I put up
almost every lecture in the
beginning of the term.
That we learn a craft by
practicing it and that we
cultivate virtues by acting as
if we were already virtuous.
If there is something that you
wish to become, act as if that
were what you already are.
And I close with, perhaps the
most beautiful part of Plato's
Republic, the myth of Er, in
which Plato describes the
story of a bunch of disembodied
souls, which
people who were about
to be born are
permitted to choose among.
They're giving models of
lives and asked to
select among them.
And it is in the context of
choosing what sort of life
that one wants to live that the
questions of this course
become most pressing.
Think over how the sorts of
things we have mentioned from
January until now jointly and
severally determine what the
virtuous life is like.
"From all this, by considering
the nature of the soul, reason
out which life is better
and which is worse.
Choose accordingly, calling a
life worse if it leads the
soul to become more unjust,
better if it leads the soul to
be more just." And remember that
on the closing page of
Plato's Republic, Odysseus, the
great hero, celebrated for
his exploits in the Trojan War,
comes to the recognition
that the life which will allow
him to flourish most is the
quiet life of a private
individual who does his own
work, who focuses on the things
around him in such a
way that he brings joy
to those near him
and thereby to himself.
And with those opening and
closing words of Plato's
Republic, I thank you for
a wonderful semester.
[APPLAUSE]